en Francia el aborto Es legal desde 1975
gracias a Simón Bale pero desde marzo
este año se alargó el plazo hasta el que
una mujer puede interrumpir
voluntariamente su embarazo de la semana
12 a la semana 14 en el Día
Internacional del aborto la organización
planning familiar que es la que Acompaña
a las mujeres que quieren hacerse un
aborto en Francia ha denunciado que hay
muy pocos centros en este país que se
hayan adaptado a esta reforma de la ley
es decir que estén realizando abortos
hasta la semana número 14 unos cuarentan
todo el país en Francia donde una de
cada tres mujeres dice al menos alguna
vez en la vida haber recurrido a un
aborto los médicos consultados dicen que
un aborto hasta la semana 14 es más
complicado porque el feto es más grande
la operación es distinta y además
sensiblemente también es diferente por
lo que se encuentra muy pocos médicos
voluntarios para realizar este tipo de
intervenciones es uno de los topes que
encuentra el derecho al aborto en
Francia El otro es la doble cláusula de
conciencia la que pueden que los médicos
es decir negarse a realizar un aborto
Aunque este sea legal y también el hecho
de que no cualquier profesional de la
salud por ejemplo las matronas no pueden
realizar cierto tipo de abortos
quirúrgicos por lo mismo y en vista de
lo que ocurrió en Estados Unidos las
asociaciones Pro aborto en Francia están
intentando inscribir este derecho en la
constitución